[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas comenzamos con las
noticias de la Guerra de Ucrania porque
fue atacada La Represa de novaka Rusia y
Ucrania se acusan mutuamente por la
destrucción de esta importante
infraestructura en la región de jerson
El hecho ha generado inundaciones una
potencial tragedia ambiental y
preocupaciones internacionales por las
implicaciones que este hecho pueda tener
para la central nuclear de saporilla así
como para el suministro de agua en la
Península de crimea Rusia dice que
Ucrania destruyó la presa para desviar
la atención de lo que califica como una
fallida contraofensiva cerca del frente
de batalla en la ciudad de mamut algunos
de los soldados ucranianos apostados
allí dicen que esta ya ha comenzado
Catherine nori strange Johan botán y
dimitro Cuba Chuck traen el siguiente
informe
justo después del amanecer en los flanco
sur de basmut estamos con la vigésima
octava brigada del ejército ucraniano
fuera de la ciudad en ruinas la batería
de 6 unidades la lidera este Teniente de
sólo 23 años el año pasado y acción en
el frente sur de Ucrania antes de ser
redesplegado directamente al
gersón usaron más artillería pero aquí
usan más mano de obra ahora en vemos
rotaciones de tropas están sacando a
Wagner y trayendo fuerzas regulares era
más difícil Cuando solo estaba Wagner
porque tenían órdenes de avanzar como
fuera sin importar las pérdidas y aquí
un extraterrestre sus drones han espiado
los rusos que abandonó nuevas trincheras
alrededor de la ciudad en ruinas Así que
escondidos en el campo han establecido
posiciones de morteros a sólo un
kilómetro de los rusos el objetivo
destruir sus defensas mientras las
construyen en las primeras horas del día
los ucranianos quieren detener
urgentemente cualquier avance ruso en
bahamut y han logrado hacerlo retroceder
A las afueras de aquí llegamos al Don
base el 3 de diciembre
la semana que viene hará 6 meses que
estamos aquí
mi hermana
[Música]
esta unidad nos dice que por fin tiene
suficiente munición al mando de la
posición de mortero está constantín
quien ha regresado de su entrenamiento
militar en el Reino Unido esta unidad
dispara Ahora hasta 50 morteros al día y
parece que poco a poco va dando sus
frutos han consolidado una serie de
pequeñas ganancias en el último mes
cuando preguntamos por la contraofensiva
más amplia de Ucrania Esta es su
respuesta
ya ha empezado el mes pasado avanzamos
100 metros luego 300 metros luego más y
así es también a lo largo de todo este
frente no será rápido esta vez no se
retirarán fácilmente vinieron aquí con
mucho equipo y tanques Así que no puedes
hacerlo retroceder fácilmente
Así que poco a poco siguen luchando
informando de que esta mañana sus
morteros han conseguido un impacto
directo y mortal
alcanzamos a una unidad de soldados al
lado de un pequeño búnker acababan de
empezar a excavarlo los vimos dos
soldados cavando uno tercero en el
búnker Y quizá alguno más no lo sé
[Risas]
participaron en la batalla por gersón en
septiembre y ahora aquí en las afueras
de bahamut han recuperado recientemente
un kilómetro de terreno por lo que la
moral está alta y realmente esperan que
esto sea un preludio de la tan anunciada
contrafensiva ucraniana
la semana pasada estallaron disturbios
en varias ciudades de senegal después de
que el candidato presidencial de la
oposición Guzmán song fue condenado a
dos años de prisión sus partidarios
levantaron barricadas en varias calles
de la capital quemaron neumáticos y
también vehículos para protestar contra
la sentencia los hechos se saltaron con
varios muertos el siguiente es un
informe de Natalia odyssaria y Sara sacó
en senegal los enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes y policía continuaron el
jueves por la noche como aquí en el
barrio de huacam de Dakar las
hostilidades más mortíferas tuvieron
lugar en la capital y mg donde Guzmán
sunco es alcalde también hubo
manifestaciones en San Luis en el norte
y en otras ciudades del país
el candidato presidencial y más acérrimo
opositor del presidente maquisal ha sido
condenado a dos años de cárcel por
corrupción de menores una condena que
podría impedirle presentarse a las
próximas elecciones justicia es decir la
verdad justicia es exculpar a nuestro
presidente usmansoncó ahora podemos
dejarle ser candidato en 2024
estamos dispuestos a acompañar al
presidente usman usanco a la victoria en
2024 porque es el líder de la juventud
no forma parte de este sistema corrupto
por su parte el gobierno asegura que no
ha interferido en la decisión del
tribunal
Nadie puede obligarle a declarar una
violación cuando no está convencido de
ello pero al mismo tiempo Tampoco puede
haber presiones de planes
insurreccionales
para asustarles y que le absuelvan al
final el juez falló según su convicción
personal y eso que refleja refleja la
imparcialidad del juez y la
independencia del poder judicial
de momento sigue en su residencia de
Dakar el gobierno que podría detenerle
en cualquier momento no ha dado fecha ni
hora para su arresto
en Alemania aumenta la presión sobre el
colectivo climático conocido como Última
Generación cuyos miembros están
especializados en pegarse al asfalto a
manera de protesta ellos afirman que se
les ha criminalizado injustamente sin
embargo las acciones policiales también
han llevado a un aumento en el
reclutamiento el siguiente es un informe
de Johnson
formación en desobediencia civil Laura y
Lily quieren convertirse en activistas
contra el cambio climático del grupo
Última Generación en este patio trasero
de Berlín practican el bloqueo de
carreteras y el trato con automovilistas
enfadados
presión psicológica extrema hay mucha
violencia es una buena manera de ver si
somos capaces de hacer este tipo de
acciones
nunca ha habido tantos candidatos para
la acción directa dice Simón su
entrenador
Cuanto más nos reprimen más se da cuenta
la gente de que el gobierno no se toma
En serio la protección del clima las
fuerzas del orden sospechan que Última
Generación forma parte de una
organización criminal se han llevado a
cabo registros y se han congelado
cuentas bancarias desde entonces se han
celebrado manifestaciones de apoyo en
toda Alemania estamos aquí para decir
que la forma en que están siendo
tratados es inaceptable lo que está
haciendo el gobierno es desproporcionado
el movimiento ya ha anunciado que
continúa con sus tácticas de choque Esto
hace nuestra tarea mucho más difícil
pero estamos dispuestos a afrontar las
consecuencias judiciales no porque sí
sino porque los cimientos de nuestra
existencia se están derrumbando Pero los
activistas que han estado bloqueando
carreteras siguen en el punto de mira de
la justicia decenas de ellos han sido
condenados apenas de prisión políticos
de todos los partidos apoyan la acción
policial
un grupo de personas organizadas y
financiadas para preparar actividades
ilegales eso se llama una organización
criminal nadie dice que sea la mafia
pero tiene que acabar ánimo
los simpatizantes han donado casi medio
millón de euros de ayuda de emergencia
al grupo suficiente para continuar su
lucha contra el cambio climático de
forma legal o ilegal
[Aplausos]
superar los límites es el objetivo de
las carreras de ciclo montañismo extremo
que se desarrollan en estos últimos años
se trata de competencias de una sola
etapa de más de 900 kilómetros en plena
naturaleza y sin asistencia en Grecia se
desarrolló la primera edición de la
helenique un recorrido exigente a través
de las montañas del norte del país hasta
el mar que pocos participantes lograron
completar el siguiente es un reportaje
de
unos paisajes espectaculares pero un
gran desafío para estos ciclo
montañistas en las montañas de Grecia
109 corredores de 21 nacionalidades como
Estefan pedalearon en la primera edición
de la helenique
es la carrera más dura que hice en mi
vida he hecho varias carreras así pero
esta Está muy difícil las subidas son
duras las bajadas también son duras
938 kilómetros
29.000 metros de desnivel una de las
carreras de ciclo montañismo más dura
del mundo
de los 109 participantes sólo 35
llegaron a la meta la mayoría como orené
y bers no pudo culminarla
así Qué pasa es el día más duro de mi
vida creo que estuve Más allá de mis
límites
este tipo de competencias se han
multiplicado los últimos años antes de
lanzar este año la helenique Nelson creó
dos otras carreras en Marruecos
para mí era corredores en lugares como
este es épico y vienen por eso buscan
este reto quieren ponerse a prueba y
probar sus límites ver hasta dónde
pueden ir y eso es lo que les da
satisfacción
una satisfacción que logró Adrián yesti
después de cuatro días 12 horas y 6
minutos el coredolsó fue El vencedor de
esta primera edición
no me doy cuenta lo que pasó estoy muy
cansado tengo frío realmente no me doy
cuenta de lo que pasó
a pesar de las dificultades la mayoría
de los corredores fueron entusiasmados y
tienen previsto participar en la próxima
competencia que se realizada en agosto
en kiebistán con un recorrido de 1880
kilómetros
queremos agradecer a café rivadavia por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa ya ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana siga con
más información en France 24 y France
24.com